[Musique]
oh
l'auto stop c'est un art où les jeunes
filles réussissent souvent mieux que les
garçons mais c'est aussi une technique
avec ces trucs honnête ou malhonnête
efficace pour rater avec ses surprises
parfois agréable et parfois non selon le
point de vue de classe
[Musique]
l'auto stop c'est encore une aventure
avec ces risques ces inconvénients ses
échecs et ses déceptions
[Musique]
c'est en fait un sport qui nécessite un
équipement particulier et demande de
nombreuses qualités
courage astuce endurance et surtout
beaucoup de patience
on a parlé d' interdire ce sport en
france en réalité il s'agit plutôt de
les encourager car nous avons peu de
champions dans cette discipline
et si beaucoup de nos automobilistes
s'arrêtent davantage encore ont tendance
à accélérer lorsqu'il voit apparaître à
l'horizon la silhouette d'un stop cela
inutile de leur faire signe mieux vaut
les gaietés lorsqu'ils sont désarmés à
pied au détour d'une station service
vous monsieur vous n'acceptez pas les
auto-stoppeurs pourquoi pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que je préfère de
très loin à rouler seul lorsque je
conduis et la seconde parce qu'il est
toujours très embêtant d'avoir un
accident parce que moins de personnes
plantent qu'on est pareils
la première raison vous ne vous ennuyez
pas lorsque vous êtes seul en voiture oh
non pas du tout j'adore l'autre mobile
j'aime l'automobile pour la conduite je
fais assez souvent de longs parcours
deux enfants par mois 2000 km aller
retour dans deux ou trois jours et je
préfère de très loin à travers le car je
conduis très vite
qu'est ce que vous reprochez augis
protestataires jeu-là reproche très
égoïstement de me dérange
ils ont soit proche soit 30 ans soit ils
veulent parler son sommet ils ne veulent
pas écouter la radio leur programme ne
leur plaît pas il m'est arrivé
la marre des gens de ma famille tripoter
mon prof la radio c'est une chose qui
nous met dans une fureur noire et
lorsque vous rencontrez une auto stop
est ce que vous êtes un peu plus
complaisant ou pas du tout j'aurais même
préjugé très défavorable car les femmes
ont la réputation d'être très peur mais
j'ai horreur de ça lorsqu'on compte et
les militaires le militaire voyez vous
je viens de terminer mon service
militaire n'ont pas tous de pitié pour
les militaires que pour les autres
m'est arrivé une histoire ce crédit il
ya un an de cela après je partais sur
perpignan comme aujourd'hui
prenons de l'essence un tour son service
à la sortie de paris il y avait là deux
militaires qui m'ont demandé de les
emmener
je suis grave de nature je n'ai pas pu
refuser
eh bien voyez-vous du côté d'orléans il
régnait déjà en en voiture une odeur que
je n'ai retrouvé dans aucune chambre et
de cazères aux environs de brive il y en
avait un qui était malade j'étais obligé
de m'arrêter pour attendre comme se
fasse des petits besoins et j'en passe
est arrivé à toulouse ces messieurs
n'ont même pas eu du tout de mon frère
un café je trouve que c'est abusé
pourtant le conducteur le plus endurci
gardent généralement au fond du coeur ne
serait-ce qu'une ombre de faiblesse à
l'égard du soldat à 33 centimes par jour
qu'il se souvient d'avoir été lorsque
c'était son tour
[Musique]
il a parfois lui-même gagné de
précieuses heures de permissions grâce à
l'amabilité d'un automobiliste
il se le rappelle et s'arrête toujours
plus volontiers en vue d'un uniforme
[Musique]
monsieur vous partez en permission est
ce que vous allez tenter le stop aux
caméras de vous en recommander de faire
du stop non et le règlement militaire il
vous le permet ou pas non cette
intervention sur un officier ou sur une
patrouille on risque au moins 60 jours
d'arrêt mais j'ai pas le droit étant
militaire est absolument pas interdit
formellement interdit de phallus top est
un militaire au contraire les gendarmes
nous ont affirmé qu'aucun texte général
ne réglemente la pratique du stop
un plus pour les civils que pour les
militaires mais ces derniers préfèrent
ne pas s'y risquer trop ouvertement il
s'efforce d'arrêter une voiture le plus
discrètement possible au besoin pour
être certain de ne pas tomber sur un
officier ils réservent leurs appels
routier
[Applaudissements]
monsieur leroux qui sont considérés
souvent comme il ya providence des auto
stoppeurs est-ce que vous arrêtez
souvent pour en embarquer dans la mesure
du possible oui mais seulement ça ne
s'est pratiquement interdit aussi ça ça
vous est interdit par qui dans les
assurances
après l'accident on n'est pas couvert
sur les accidents des assurances nous
décrit toute responsabilité on n'a pas
le droit de vous paye pas d'assurance
spéciale pour transporter les stoppeurs
quand on connaît quand on connaît
quelqu'un nous on voit où un colloque
qui remplace on les dépanne seulement ça
nous est interdite par un volet
militaire aussi ces interdictions juste
un peu mais vous emmener ce double même
des militaires de temps en temps vous
hri sites sont prévus soit patient qu'on
les connaît où l'on en soit que la route
est libre ou sans gêne pas aux efforts
pour les foules mauvais temps la nuit on
leur programme pitié quoi c'est pas
dangereux l'auto-stop la nuit ça dépend
comment quel point de vue on se place
évidemment il ya eu tellement de blagues
de fêtes et une douche au corps à corps
être un truc mais vient aussi des petits
rigolos qui font notre stop
il vous faut faire deux à mettre des
guillemets matraque ça vous est arrivé
où c'est arrivé à certains de vos
collègues south arriver à un collègue
jamais jamais arrivé à moi au nom un
supporter le moins chaud le dos et que
tu arrêtes mais oui il me faut que ça
pour que je connais souvent leur faut
vraiment un cas spécial
et vous monsieur est-ce que vous emmenez
les auto-stoppeurs quelques fois hors
des fois bon pour souvent pourquoi bas
cenon jean-francis un militaire je vais
le prendre mais si c'est des vacanciers
c'est voir avec leurs bagages et les
auto stoppeuse durablement goût il avait
pas pour quelle direction monsieur vous
êtes souvent arrêtés par des auto
stoppeurs ça arrive sur ok un assaut
voire de la route surtout en période des
vacances
et est ce que vous vous arrêtez non pas
tellement parce que les patrons ne sont
pas assurés d'avoir pour ça et puis on
risque plutôt de voir des embêtements si
ça nous arrive un accident et la nuit
est ce que voulaient embarquer riez s'il
était assurée oui c'est plus compliqué
parce qu'on sait jamais à qui on a
affaire mais enfin s'isoler par exemple
une carte réglementaires ont produit
répond monsieur amené vous des auto
stoppeurs quelquefois non jamais
pourquoi parce qu'on risque beaucoup
d'accidents et depuis c'est un principe
la dernière transports monsieur vous ne
prenez pas d'auto stop n'ont su pourquoi
première monte dans ce seul rouge est
interdite dans la maison va au culot
travailler premièrement par notre bâton
et deuxièmement c'est quand même une
responsabilité pour nous quoi on vous a
donné des instructions précises
interdisant d'embarquer les
auto-stoppeurs eu assez sérieux et qu on
allait
les pancartes et vous sous peine de
renvoi immédiat il est formellement
interdit d'effectuer avec ce véhicule
tout transport de personnel marchandises
étrangères l'objet de son service et
aucun de vos collègues ne passe par
dessus cette au real
sinon qu'est ce qui vous arrive si on
est passé sur la route et on se réfère
la mettre dehors on est licenciée de la
légende
malgré l'obligeance des routiers les
auto-stoppeurs ne sont jamais certain de
trouver une voiture qui aille où ils
veulent et qu'ils partent quand ils
veulent pour être certain de partir les
étudiants peuvent s'adresser à un
organisme d'auto-stop permanent madame
valter vous dirigez l'auto-stop
permanent qui s'appelle pro va ya qu'est
ce que ça veut dire pro bayard pro
voyage c'est une association d'étudiants
qui est spécialisée dans la mise en
relation de passagers qui désirent
voyager et qui participe aux frais
d'essence avec les automobilistes qui
peuvent sembler et le nom même de brevet
no que signifie et bien c'est en même
temps le numéro de téléphone on peut
former sur le cadran toutes les lettres
pont ouailles à désirer j'aurais pu
partir avignon aux environs du 25
juillet
vous êtes une passagère passagère ou
aussi la première fois que vous venez
ici à prendre vous savez comment cela se
passe nous avait une cotisation ici qui
est de 5 20 ces petits nation est
valable pour une année ou deux voyages
alors ensuite vous arranger avec
l'automobiliste pour la participation
aux frais 10 ans qui peut vous demander
il appartient en principe une moyenne de
3,4 centimes par kilomètre alors vous
voulez je vous inscrire oui bien sûr bon
mademoiselle pourquoi vous êtes vous
adresser à pro variable dubaï à bord je
me décide d'en je suis allé passer
maison à l'économique sienne et j'ai vu
une affiche et j'ai trouvé sorte comme
mode de voyage et économie c'est pour
faire des économies sur vos vacances
très certainement est ce que ça ne nous
inquiète pas un petit peu de montées
avec un automobiliste que vous ne
connaîtrez pas de faire des kilomètres
avec lui jusqu'ici j'ai pratiqué assez
souvent assez pour interdite en france
qui l'auto stop et sans trop d'ennuis
c'est pourquoi présente
vous aimez [ __ ] tostat où vous le fait
parce que vous ne pouvez pas faire
autrement
d'une part il ya vraiment des raisons et
d'autres pas l intérêt tout simplement
humain parce qu'en traversant les
régions je me devais d'être présent par
des autochtones de bien connaître les
problèmes par exemple particulier à la
main d'oeuvre on discute avec les
ingénieurs qui me demandait vert je ne
sais pas vers ce lieu par exemple où il
avait une usine et ça m'a permis d'avoir
une connaissance humaine des régions
avec les routiers aussi j'ai pu
connaître mieux parmi vous avez beaucoup
voyagé avec les routiers très peu
d'étagés surtout faire d'abord pour et
raison gardée de concevoir comment
c'était très amusant ajouté dans un gros
camion nos vies mais l'assistant tous
ses trajets longs le confort qui vous a
fait venir à propre ayari n'est pas près
de pouvoir choisir une voiture
américaine ou non qu'importe la voiture
l'essentiel est d'arriver je dirais à
l'endroit ça ne vous ennuie pas un petit
peu de laisser tomber un peu le côté
aventureux de l'auto-stop
en venant ici non ça je crois que
connaissent enfin chercher le risque
pour le plaisir du oui ce que c'était
vraiment un minimum de de sécurité
monsieur vous êtes automobilistes pouvez
vous me dire si vous offrez souvent des
places à provoquer et bien ça m'arrive
de temps en temps parce que j'ai une
voiture assez spacieuse et qu' il
m'arrive de faire des déplacements avec
quelques places de libres et j'aime bien
le système de propria parce que ça me
permet de
réglez connaître les gens avant de
partir et ça permet aussi de faire payer
par les passagers une partie de
l'essence mais vous avez besoin de cet
argent
non mais je suis peut être économe et
d'autres bars je sais que ça rend
service à aux gens j'emmène de pouvoir
voyager à des prix très bas et ça m'a
permis de ne pas siffler à avoir une
voiture très spacieuse qui comprend six
places très confortable heureusement les
automobilistes ne demande pas toujours
d'argent aux auto stop et les jeunes les
auberges de la jeunesse par exemple
seraient souvent bien en peine de payer
leur passage
monsieur est ce que ça vous est arrivé
qu'on vous demande de l'argent pour vous
transporter qui m'est arrivé une seule
fois c'était la sortie de permis est et
je voulais devenir technique fédéral
j'attendais depuis près de trois ans et
je commençais vraiment à être désespérés
ils de chevaux qui s'arrêtent de choix
du matricule en allemagne est votre type
commence à me dire monter dans
l'habitude
commence à porter vous à faire une petit
ce sera dit moi je crois alors j'ai
refusé mais non tendue parce que c'était
surtout pour le sport je le fais on
avait fait de l'auto-stop la nuit ou
mais très peu c'est plus facile ou plus
difficile que le jeu est bien les gens'
les gens s'arrêtera peut-être plus
volontiers la nuit enfin étant donné la
rareté des voitures durant la nuit
j'ai quand même en fin de compte ou plus
ennuyeux de jours est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas un peu inquiet quand vous montez la
nuit avec un automobiliste que vous ne
connaissez pas non personnellement je
pense monsieur est ce que vous croyez
que si on faisait une réglementation de
l'auto stop si par exemple vous délivrer
en même temps que votre carte à
l'auberge de la jeunesse une carte
d'auto stoppeur qui vous assure ray ce
que vous croyez que ça marcherait mieux
le pense je crois que ça existe dans
certains pays en pologne une croix en
pologne
les auto stoppeurs ont un carnet de
timbres il donne des tables aux
automobilistes et à la fin d'année
l'automobiliste qu'elle puisse de talent
à une récompense est ce que vous pensez
qu'une méthode comme celle ci serait
profitable en france je pense que oui
non pas tellement en se plaçant au point
de vue de l'auto stoppeur parce que je
crois que cela changera strictement rien
pour lui mais on se placera au point de
vue de l'automobiliste parce que les
français sont peut-être dans ce domaine
la tâche une certaine importance aux
principes pour le principe le haut
commissariat à la jeunesse et aux sports
envisage aujourd'hui de créer une carte
elle permettrait d'assurer les stoppeurs
et de rassurer les automobilistes
[Musique]
mais le dernier mot restera au
conducteur car avec ou sans carte rien
ni personne ne les obligera jamais à
s'arrêter
[Musique]
alors merci à vous demander si vous
acceptez les auto-stoppeurs non pas du
tout pourquoi encore ce qui leur est
tellement d'histoires pas volontiers
mais les militaires surtout avec
septembre
je prends quelques militaires devant
quand ils ont une bonne tête pourquoi on
sait pas toujours ce qu'ils entendent
non non non pourquoi monsieur parce
qu'il ya eu des précédents tragique et
si vous avez une carte qui les assurait
est ce que vous les accepteriez
occasionnellement en attendant il ne
reste qu'à conseillé aux implants qui
auto stoppeur de se placer le plus loin
des carrefours et des virages où ils
entravent la circulation alors
recommandé de soigner leurs tenues qui
est leur meilleure arme de persuasion et
à leur souhaiter bonne chance
[Musique]
c'était un reportage de micha friedman
l'image de gilbert becker sont henri
molines mixage paul bertho montage
daniel lambert
[Musique]